So we have seen that performing these atomic read
write operations on the lock repeatedly even while waiting
for the lock is inefficient in terms of energy
and it actually slows down the thread that is in
the critical section. We want to make this more
efficient and one way of doing that is to do
a so-called test and atomic op approach in the
locking function. So the original approach to using for example,
an atomic exchange is to set R1 to 1, and as long as R1 is 1, try to swap
between lock var, eventually we see a 0 and we exit. But as we now know, this
keeps invalidating everybody else who is waiting on the
lock, so we are getting a lot of cache
misses while waiting. And active waiting like this is
not only spending energy on the bus transfers all the
time, but also keeps the bus busy so that
useful work in other trays that are not busy
waiting, you slow down. So this is kind of
like a repeated atomic op approach. To make it
more efficient, what we do is we do the
same type of looping here, but we don't immediately
try to swap. What we do first is use
normal loads to wait for lockvar to become zero.
So the idea is that were using normal loads
while lockvar is busy. If we observe that its free,
we try to grab it by doing an atomic
exchange. We cannot try to grab it using the normal
store, that's why we have to do the exchange.
Bu the idea is that there is no point in
trying to do the exchange unless the lock is actually
free and the purpose of the exchange now is solely
to ensure that only one of us grabs the lock once it becomes free. But the busy
waiting while the lock is continuously free is
done using normal reads. So now if we have
core zero, one, and two, and core zero
succeeds in doing an exchange, and gets the lockvar
in the modified state. Core one will now reach
this point and read lockvar. See that it's one.
It's done using a normal load, so here we're
moved to the own state, here we are moved
to the shared state. And there is a cache
to cache transfer here. Now we will keep doing
this, but we'll keep getting cache hits so we
no longer access the bus while waiting. Similarly core
two will load the lockvar. It will also get
the value and have it in the shared state.
And now it also gets cached hits while
waiting. So as long as core zero keeps the
lock busy here, these two cores are no
longer generating bus traffic. So core zero basically gets
the entire coherence bus to itself so it
can very quickly service cache misses. And cache hits
here are much more efficient than bus accesses.
And this is going to continue until core zero
releases the lock, at which point, there is an
invalidation, and these two will read again, see a
value of one, try to compete for it using
the exchange and so on. But those bursts of
activity really happen only when they're actually trying to
acquire the lock. As long as the lock is
really busy, they just keep using normal loads in
this loop. So this is much more energy efficient.